- All right, before we roll the credits,
I wanna share one final
heartwarming story for the day.
This is what I'm liking.
(upbeat music)
Today is the last day of
National Nurses Month,
but let's be honest, these past two years
have proven every day is a good day
to show gratitude to our nurses.
I think we all agree on that.
Sorry, I'm losing my voice.
You may be familiar with the
Northwell Health Nurse Choir.
They were featured on
AGT, got the golden buzzer
from Howie and made it to
the coveted top 10 spot.
And I'm happy to say the
choir's still going strong.
Bur bur bur!
We have one of the members
on the line right now with an update.
So let's say hi to nurse Keisha
who watches on NBC New York.
(audience applause and cheers)
Hi, Keisha!
- Kelly.
- Oh my gosh. You have a beautiful smile.
I'm gonna lead with that.
So for those who don't know
tell us more about your
very special choir.
- All right. So we formed back in 2020
as part of a virtual concert
for Nurse Heroes Live.
We come from all different specialties.
We come from New York and we're a part
of 19,000 nurses in our health
system, Northwell Health.
And we did a virtual concert back in 2020.
We auditioned for America's
Got Talent for season 16.
It's just crazy.
You know, it's a monumental moment
in my life and it's something
that I would never forget.
And, you know, in light of
nurses, National Nurses Month,
we performed all across New York
for our peers and our
colleagues and our profession.
And we're just so honored.
Matter of fact, a couple
days ago, we performed
at Side by Side, which is a two
day national Northwell event
that honors military workers and veterans
and their families and healthcare workers.
Jason Derulo opened, and
John legend headlined.
- Ahhh.
- And, you know, it was just
so crazy to be there.
Just hope to continue spreading this love
and this joy and this hope and healing
through our music, honestly.
We provide care at the
bedside every single day.
And it's just, it's just
an honor that we're able
to do that with our voices
to impact our listeners
and impact America.
(audience applause)
- Absolutely. I bet that
was a good show too.
Y'all singing Jason and John.
That was probably really
great. Oh, that's awesome.
- Just to have our name
in the same sentence as
John Legend is an honor.
- Oh my gosh. I'm with
you. I feel the same way.
So, I'm liking your post right now, right?
- [Keisha] Thank you, Kelly!
- And that's not all!
Our season long partner,
Pilot pen makers of G2,
the go-to pen of the Kelly Clarkson Show,
want to honor ultimate
overachievers just like you ma'am.
So they're gonna be writing you a check
for a thousand dollars.
How's that sound?
(audience cheers and applause)
- What?! Oh my goodness.
Thank you so much!
- I know. Have some,
have some fun with that!